Good morning John! I'm rotating through my
posters. That's right. I'm on my wall.
So a couple of weeks ago I introduced you
to some of the people of Savann Tabak, a village
that I visited while I was in Haiti. Genna
and Ulna and Isaiid and Botes and Jan Baptiste.
So right after we first met the people of
Savann Tabak, they decided to take us on a
walk to where they are currently getting their
water. Now the first thing that we see on
this walk is the broken well, the well that
was built at some point and broke who knows
how long ago. Several of the older members
of Savann Tabak had a great time arguing about
when the well last worked. There was no consensus,
but there was a great deal of arguing, which
is, I guess, one of the ways that you pass
the time while you're walking to the well.
So we were walking, and, um, walking some
more, and then we were still walking, and
then we got to the sugar cane mill. So here's
what happens. They take the sugar cane, and
they run it through a mill that basically
squishes the sugar cane and squeezes all the
cane juice out. The cane juice that has been
squeezed out of the sugar cane is then placed
in giant vats, boiled with fires fueled by
the spent stalks of sugar cane, and then it
becomes a thick brown syrup, and that thick
brown syrup is then put into barrels And then
it's shipped off, and they ferment it into
rum, which is then sold in Port au Prince.
So after our tour of the sugar cane processing
plant, we walked a little more, and then we
kept walking. And then we walked some more,
and I kept seeing these houses on stilts,
and I had to ask about that. And I was told
that in fact people don't live up there; uh,
food is kept up there, and the stilts are
so they can block rodents.
It's basically the exact same idea as a squirrel-proof
bird feeder, except that instead of one pole,
there's four poles, and instead of bird food,
it's human food. And instead of squirrels,
it's rats.
And then we walked some more, and we kept
walking, and we were walking when someone
gave me some sugar cane. And it was really
good; it tasted like honey, but wetter, and
also different from that.
I took our guide's lead, and I broke mine
into three pieces, and I gave two pieces to
little kids. And then my first thought was
"But should those kids be having so much sugar?",
and then I immediately felt like a douche.
Among the many problems I encountered in Haiti,
childhood obesity, not one of them. Isaiid
said that my teeth must be rotten like his
are if I didn't want all the sugar cane for
myself, but Genna defended me and said that
I was just a nice guy.
And we walked some more, and then I stopped
to admire the cactus fence because everything
in central Haiti is fenced by cactuses. And
then we walked some more, and then we got
to the spring, and this is not what I pictured
when they said spring; this is a muddy hole
in the ground. Five minutes ago, I was worrying
whether these kids were eating too much sugar,
and now I'm looking at the warm, muddy hole
in the ground where they get their water.
As we were walking back, the translator was
talking to Jan Baptiste, and I could tell
that something had gone wrong in the conversation,
and I didn't know what, and I didn't ask at
the time, but later, I asked our translator
what had happened. She was asking Jan Baptiste
what the village had done for Carnival this
year, and Carnival is like the biggest, funnest
time in Haiti. And Jan Baptiste said that,
uh, they had done nothing this year for Carnival,
and our translator wouldn't believe her; she
said "Of course you must have done something
fun for Carnival, just a little something."
And Jan Baptiste was a voiding the subject,
and finally she just came out and decided
to tell her that right around that time, about
six people, in a village of sixty households,
had died of cholera.
Cholera is not a nice disease, and if you
have it and don't get to a doctor or a hospital
within a couple of days, there's a really
good chance that you die. People get cholera
from drinking dirty water. Dirty water like
the water I saw those women getting for their
children that day. What they need is a well
and an infrastructure within their community
to help that well be a sustainable source
of water for the lifetime of that community.
And that's what Water.org is going to get
for them.
If you go to my.water.org/vlogbrothers, you
will see the progress of Savann Tabak on the
path to getting that sustainable water source,
and you can give Water.org money so that they
can help the people of Savann Tabak and other
people in similar situations throughout the
world.
I'm going to make one more video about Haiti,
and in that video, I'm going to talk about
how Water.org and their member organizations
are different and how they are changing the
entire model of charity from the one where
you create people who are dependent on charity
into one where you create people who become
independent.
I hope that you are looking forward to that
video; I am looking forward to making it.
John, I'll see you on Wednesday.